morning I'm ski bridge near the managing
director of Cisco in emerging Asia and
I'm responding to nandos question on how
to make education more accessible in
environments like Indonesia nando
essentially the first thing that we have
to provide is as broad an access to
broadband connections to the Internet as
we possibly can now that connectivity to
the internet could take the form of
smartphones on a mobile network or it
could be a hard wired connection like
dsl for example once we have that
enabled we can easily scale content
using video on demand witnesses or video
streaming to probe ring high impact
education to people in broad reaches of
the globe on demand at the right time
that's applicable to you and of course
we can begin to scale our resources that
may be for example at the university in
America across the internet using video
as a mass of saying that content down
into wherever you may be in Indonesia
the great thing about this of course is
that if you never material unless that
lecture as an example because it was
given on American time and you were
received at the time you can then wake
up the next morning access the video
stream and also have access to their 20
I hope that answers your question and
good luck in educating yourself